ya sabemos que cada cromosoma se compone
de una molécula de adn muy larga toda
enrollada en sí misma algo como esto y
en esta molécula se encuentran las
secuencias a las que llamamos genes
este podría ser un gen
este podría ser otro gen
este también podría ser un gen
y cada uno de estos genes puede
codificar para polipéptidos específicos
o proteínas específicas y la pregunta
clave es cómo se pasa de la información
codificada en estos genes que está
codificada como secuencias de adn como
se pasa del gen que está codificado en
el adn a las proteínas que se componen
de polipéptidos que están formados por
aminoácidos y esto es a menudo llamado
el dogma central de la biología y ya
vimos en el vídeo de la transcripción
que el primer paso es ir del gen al rn
mensajero el rn mensajero se puede ver
como una copia o una transcripción hemos
reescrito la información ahora como rn y
el siguiente paso que es el que vamos a
ver la profundidad en este vídeo es
pasar del arn mensajero a la proteína y
a este proceso se le denomina traducción
porque estamos traduciendo literalmente
la información en una secuencia poli
peptídica
puedes ver aquí esto es solo un repaso
ya que vimos mucho de esto en el vídeo
de transcripción y en el vídeo de
resumen de la transcripción y la
traducción así que si nos fijamos en una
célula eucariota y en una célula
procariotas como son las bacterias
notamos que son análogas simplemente
éstas no tienen membrana nuclear y no
van a llevar a cabo el paso de
procesamiento del cual voy a hablar en
un momento más y también lo vimos a
detalle en el vídeo sobre la
transcripción así que se empieza con el
adn
tenemos el arn polimerasa como el actor
principal que es capaz de transcribir el
arn a partir del adn si estamos hablando
de una célula eucariota lo que obtenemos
en este paso no lo llamamos nm lo
llamamos pre nm
que luego necesita ser procesado los
cinturones deben ser eliminados añadimos
una cabeza y una cola aquí y si estamos
hablando de una célula eucariota
entonces llamamos formalmente a esto a
efe nm y luego aquí es donde pasamos a
la etapa de traducción
el inm puede viajar a un ribosoma que es
donde será traducido en una secuencia
poli peptídica y podemos ver como esto
sucede de manera análoga aquí en esta
bacteria o célula procar jetta excepto
que no se ve la membrana nuclear porque
es una célula procariotas y no ocurre la
etapa de procesamiento por lo que esto
es a efe nm
así que te puedes estar preguntando cómo
sucede esto y qué es un ribosoma así que
vamos a hacer un acercamiento a un
ribosoma por aquí y hay un par de
actores interesantes aquí uno como te
puedes imaginar es el ribosoma en sí que
se compone de proteínas
y proteínas
y a rn ribosomal
así que en el vídeo de la transcripción
nos familiarizamos con el mensajero y a
menudo vemos a la función del arn como
similar a la del adn principalmente como
la codificación de información está
actuando como una transcripción de un
gen pero esa no es su única función
también puede tener un papel estructural
funcional que ejerce cuando está en
forma de arne ribosomas y así esto que
parece un enorme pan de hamburguesa y
esto es una simplificación excesiva de
la estructura de un ribosoma y te invito
a que busques en internet imágenes de
los ribosomas para que así puedas tener
una mayor apreciación de lo hermosas que
son estas estructuras y lo intrincadas
que realmente son así que este es el
lugar y en términos generales se puede
pensar en la estructura del ribosoma
como esta parte superior el pan de
arriba y la parte inferior el pan de
abajo el ribosoma va a viajar a lo largo
del nm desde el extremo 5 prima al
extremo 3 prima
leyéndolo y tomando toda esa información
para convertirla en una secuencia de
aminoácidos y como sucede todo esto
bueno a cada conjunto de tres
nucleótidos lo llamamos un codón así que
este es un codón
estos tres nucleótidos forman un cordón
este es un colon y este es otro codón y
la información se encuentra codificada
en las bases nitrogenadas por lo que
este primer codón de aquí vemos que es a
g por lo que las bases nitrogenadas son
adenina ur asilo y guanina y este codón
codifica para el aminoácido metionina
y este clan auge es conocido como el
codón de inicio
gordon
d
inicio
y aquí es donde el ribosoma se va a unir
inicialmente para empezar a traducir el
mensajero en este dibujo podemos ver que
apenas está comenzando a traducirse el
arn mensajero entonces como sucede esto
cómo podemos llegar de estas tres
secuencias de letras aminoácidos
específicos vamos a pensar en ello
cuántas secuencias de tres letras puede
haber bueno hay cuatro bases
nitrogenadas por lo que si tenemos un
colon que tiene tres lugares hay cuatro
cosas posibles que podrían estar en el
primer lugar hay cuatro cosas posibles
que podrían estar en el segundo lugar y
hay cuatro cosas posibles que podrían
estar en el tercer lugar así que hay 64
permutaciones posibles cuatro por cuatro
por cuatro
permutaciones
por lo que puedes pensar en que hay 64
cordones diferentes 64 maneras
diferentes de organizarla a la uv y lage
y eso es bueno porque hay muchos
aminoácidos y esto es en realidad
demasiado porque hay 22 aminoácidos
estándar 22
amino ácidos aminoácidos
estándar
y 21 que se encuentran comúnmente en las
células eucariotas así que tenemos más
que suficientes permutaciones para
cubrir los diferentes aminoácidos y
podemos encontrar tablas que nos
muestran los aminoácidos para los que
codifican las secuencias podemos ver
aquí que se puede tomar la primera la
segunda y la tercera letra y ver las
diferentes secuencias y decir a g
adenina brasil o guanina ese codón
codifica para metionina se podría hacer
eso con cualquier codón se podría ver si
tocina ahora si logras y lo que codifica
para la leucina y se puede ver que no es
sólo un aminoácido porque adán aquí
tenemos cuatro cordones que codifican
para leucina y resulta que 61 de los
cordones déjame escribir eso 61
cordones de los posibles 64 codifican
para los aminoácidos amino ácidos y 3
fueron un papel que esencialmente le
indica al ribosoma que se detenga tres
cordones son los cordones de terminación
y podemos verlos aquí
y ag y ojea así es cómo ribosomas sabe
que debe de tener la traducción por lo
que auge es el cordón de inicio y
codifica para la metionina lo que nos
indica que estas cadenas poli peptídicas
van a comenzar con metionina y luego
estos cordones le indican dónde
detenerse pero cómo se unen los
aminoácidos para formar un polipéptido y
cómo se consigue que se unan con el
codón apropiado y es aquí donde aparece
otro factor éste es el arn y late
significa transferencia
rn de transferencia
a rn de
transferencia
hay un montón de arn de diferentes y
cada uno se combina con aminoácidos
específicos también en partes
específicas de los arnette están los
llamados anti cordones que se unen con
su cordón complementario por lo que éste
arnette y no se ven así realmente en un
momento les mostraré cómo se ve
realmente el arte esta es una molécula
de arn
rn que en un extremo de la molécula está
unido al aminoácido apropiado metionina
justo aquí y luego en el otro extremo de
la molécula aunque en realidad se
encuentra en medio de la cadena de arnet
se encuentra el anti codón y el antiguo
banco incide con el cordón
complementario y así ellos chocan entre
sí de la manera correcta los ribosomas
facilitan este proceso de manera que el
auge se va a unir con la metionina y si
nos fijamos en la forma que tienen
arnette y esto es sólo una
representación aquí tenemos una
de arnet y ya tenemos la idea de que es
una secuencia de arn y podríamos pensar
en ella como una estructura de dos
dimensiones pero luego vemos aquí que se
enrolla alrededor de sí misma para
formar esta molécula compleja y el
anticuado que está justo aquí
prácticamente a la mitad de la secuencia
forma la base para este extremo de la
molécula esa es la parte que se va a
unir con el cordón en el arn m y en el
otro extremo de la molécula es donde
realmente se hace el enlace con el
aminoácido correspondiente y se lo que
estás pensando
veo que el ribosoma sabe por dónde
empezar empieza en el cordón de inicio
veo como el arnette apropiado puede
traer el aminoácido apropiado pero como
se forma la cadena y eso se puede ver en
tres pasos y a esos tres pasos se
asocian tres sitios en el ribosoma a los
cuales vamos a llamar sitio a
sitio
este es el sitio p
y este es el sitio
y en un momento más les diré por qué los
llamamos ap y el sitio es un lugar donde
el arte apropiado se une inicialmente el
arte que se encuentra unido a un
aminoácido y así como puedes ver estamos
empezando el proceso de traducción el
que tiene un anti colon que corresponde
al colon
y se va a unir aquí en el sitio a y trae
consigo el aminoácido apropiado trae el
aminoácido tirosina y por qué se les
llama sitio
bueno la representa a mí no así una
manera sencilla de recordarlo es que es
el lugar donde el arn que está unido al
aminoácido apropiado se va a enlazar en
el ribosoma y una vez que eso sucede una
vez que esté arnette se une aquí
permítanme dibujarlo
va a ser a
y está unido a la tirosina
entonces se forma un enlace peptídicos
entre los dos aminoácidos y el ribosoma
se va a mover a la derecha de manera que
éste arnette estará ahora en el sitio e
este arnette entonces estará en el sitio
pep y así el sitio estará disponible
para otro arnette que traerá otro
aminoácido entonces por qué se llaman
sitios p y lo podemos ver un poco más
claramente por aquí el sitio p es donde
se está formando la cadena poli
peptídica y una manera de recordarlo es
que es ahí donde se está formando la
cadena poli peptídica y ahora el sitio a
está disponible para recibir un nuevo
aminoácido
y una vez que esto está unido aquí se
forma el enlace peptídica y a
continuación el ribosoma se desplaza
hacia la derecha
cuando el ribosoma se desplaza a la
derecha vamos a estar en esta posición
donde lo que estaba aquí en el sitio
ahora tiene el poli péptido unido por lo
que ahora va a pasarse al sitio p
y lo que estaba en el sitio p
y ahora va a estar en el sitio
ya está listo para salir y se llama
sitio debido a la palabra en inglés para
salida exit porque el sitio
es la salida de los arneses sin
aminoácidos y esto va a seguir
ocurriendo hasta llegar a uno de los
cordones de terminación y cuando se
llega a uno de los cordones de
terminación del polipéptido adecuado va
a ser liberado y habremos creado esta
cosa que podría ser una proteína o una
parte de una proteína
así que esto es muy emocionante porque
esto está sucediendo en tus células en
este momento de hecho si pensamos en
cosas como los antibióticos la forma en
que trabajan es que los ribosomas de las
células procariotas son suficientemente
diferentes a los ribosomas en las
plantas y animales o en las células
eucariotas que podemos encontrar
moléculas que perjudican la función de
los ribosomas en las células procariotas
pero no afectan a las células eucariotas
por lo que si tienes bacterias en el
torrente sanguíneo y te tomas un
antibiótico apropiado
podrías interrumpir este proceso de
traducción en las bacterias pero no en
tus células